[Music]
thank you very much Alan thanks for this
very nice introduction it's my great
pleasure to be here CFR has been like a
home for me for for now oh my god
eighteen years and according to my wife
it's been too much like a home I spend
too much time with z-bar but this is
also a special event because you know
it's it's the David dodge lecture and I
think I'm very very honored to have been
asked to deliver this lecture and and I
think given David dodges many
contributions to intellectual and policy
world in Canada I think the topics of
today's lecture are probably important
to emphasize and re-emphasize especially
in the context of many discussions and
anxieties that exist in the Puffin
public's mind so without further ado let
me jump into the today's lecture so
there have been huge changes in the
labor market of the United States Canada
and many other advanced nations over the
last three decades and this has of
course come at the heels of major
technological transformations in the way
that we live our lives we produce we
consume we interact with each other and
especially with the increased importance
of robotics and AI in many workplaces
people have started asking questions
whether this really spells the end of
work as we know it whether machines are
going to make humans redundant or much
more limited in the functions that they
perform whether the type of work that we
are used to which is meaningful and a
source of sort of good living and wage
growth over time has come to an end and
I will show you some data in a second to
to sort of underscore that some of these
concerns have some connection to the
trends that we are observing and these
are centrally important questions
because unless we think correctly based
on scientific and historical knowledge
about how technology is going to impact
work we are going to be hampered both
because anxiety is going to take the
place of reasoned action and because our
approach to policy or other sorts of
corrective actions is going to be
delayed or totally misplaced so it is
important to have a continued
conversation on this which will include
of course people who are at the
forefront of the AI robotics technology
computer technology as well as social
scientists from different parts of the
academic divide but it is also important
to emphasize that we have been here
before
the anxiety about technology that we are
experiencing right now is not an
entirely new phenomenon one of the
Giants of the economics profession John
Maynard Keynes wrote a variant
well-delivered a very interesting
address in 1929 which he wrote up in
1930 and I say about the world that we
are going to leave to our grandchildren
and in in that essay he got many things
right in particular he was very very
much on target in predicting steady
about 2% a year productivity growth
increasing prosperity and technological
improvements but on one point people
have always thought that he was wrong in
the same essay he also predicted that we
would be experiencing increasing
technological unemployment because
machines would be replacing workers as
our productivity increases he thought
there wouldn't be enough jobs for people
to go around we always taught to our
students that you know even Keynes could
get things wrong and there are strong
reasons for thinking
that that's not true but now the same
fears have come back again perhaps with
some justification we'll see another
important economists and other a Nobel
prize-winner Wassily Leontief about 30
years after that started writing about
concerns about machines replacing people
and later on not in 52 but a little bit
later he also came up with a very
evocative image that we might be just
like horses you know in the 19th century
was impossible to imagine the world
without horses because we depended on
them for everything the world would come
to an end without horses and then huge
technological advances internal
combustion engine trams trains and and
better ships came along and transport
totally shifted away from animal power
and horses became you know essentially
unseen in cities and just a hobby sort
of activity well he said could we go the
same way of the horses so in order to
see whether those concerns that have
been around with us are more apt today
we need to delve into this issue so this
is what I'm going to do and I'm gonna
talk a little bit about a conceptual
framework about what technologies do in
relation to their interactions with
humans and in that context I'm going to
draw a key distinction it's an abstract
distinction but are useful nonetheless
between what I'm going to call enabling
technologies and replacing technologies
and I will put computers AI and robotics
within that framework once I have given
you a little bit of this frameworks
moving pieces then I will move on to
show various pieces of data about what's
been happening in the US labor market
what's going on to productivity what's
going on to employment to labor share to
wages to wage distribution and to the
occupational distribution of employment
and in that context I'll then come back
to more specific estimates of what the
effects of the rollout of robots in US
manufacturing has done and and then
based on what we have learned from here
I will come back and talk about the
future input
in regards to what it promises for
productivity and what it might hold for
the future of work okay so what do I
mean by enabling and replacing
technologies essentially this is a
distinction that of course is to some
degree abstract and many technologies
you might think might fall within both
categories but I'll show you that many
technologies that are important can be
seen to be much more on the enabling or
much more of the replacing zone by
enabling technologies I mean the
technologies that increase the
productivity of labour in the tasks that
day that Labour performs so if you are
putting together a particular model of
an airplane and you come up with a
technology to do that in a better way
that's an enabling technology and
replacing technology on the other hand
does something quite different it takes
away the tasks by automating it so that
humans are no longer necessary for that
specific purpose
so therefore the difference between
enabling and replacing is that enabling
increases augments what humans do
replacing gets rid of the human at least
for most of what is involved in
performing a particular specific task in
the production process so let me give
you some examples of what I mean by that
forced from historical technologies and
also then from contemporary technologies
in terms of the first computer I think
people can have very different opinions
about what the first computer was but
one argument is that this mechanism that
you're seeing there is actually the
first computer because it had many of
the features of something that you could
program in order to increase the
transmission of knowledge so this is
called ITT rangatira Antikythera
mechanism it goes back to about 200 BC
and it is a
a device used by a very small subsection
of the ancient Greek society in order to
predicting the astronomical positions of
stars so it's a clear enabling
technology because what it is doing is
that it's enabling these very skilled
Greek astronomers to do things that they
were not able to do before in contrast
here is another more computer like
technology that has also been heralded
as the grandfather of modern computers
it's a it's called the jacquard loom
it's a power loom that was introduced by
a French engineer and it essentially
automates part of the textile production
the weaving part of the textile
production process and it has the first
use of the punch card this is one of a
series of power looms that automated the
weaving process and took Weaver's out of
the production process and it's things
actually that are quite similar to the
jacquard loom where being used until 30
40 years ago so these are of course
ancient technologies but if you want to
sort of think of modern times you can
similarly find many examples of enabling
and replacing technology and of course
many examples that will be somewhere
between the enabling and and the
replacing spectrum so one clear example
would be computer assisted design so
these sorts of machines have increased
the ability of design workers to produce
very precise designs very quickly in a
way that augments their skills and
abilities to a to an extent that was not
possible before these computerized
technologies on the other hand the
archetypal example of a replacing
technology today is robotics so this is
a picture of a Quinn dye Factory and
what's remarkable here is that you won't
see many workers there's one there in
the background I don't know what he's
doing but this is a fully
automated workplace so that's the
difference between enabling and
replacing the computer assisted design
machine is not going to work without
somebody designing something so it is
enabling that person to do something
more than he or she was able to do
before
whereas here these robots have replaced
workers from the assembly line and of
course you can put your many
applications of AI which I'm going to
talk about later in the talk within the
category of AI so many of the
applications of AI that have not really
been introduced yet but there are in the
process of being introduced where you're
going to have a I prepared paralegal
documents financial predictions tax
accounts decision making processes are
all in the replacing category and this
distinction between replacing and
enabling technologies is important
because they create very different
effects on the labor market so why as
economists and here I'm not separate
from the rest of the economists for 20
years I've taught just like the rest of
the economists that Keynes was wrong and
technological change even if it did
bring some disruption would ultimately
lead to both employment and wage growth
why did we think that we thought that
because our framework for thinking about
technologies was very buzz based on
enabling technologies and enabling
technologies imply one very simple point
about the effects of technologies on the
labor market when a technology increases
productivity it also increases wages
there is no way for enabling
technologies to reduce wages overall
perhaps depending on how you think about
them they might reduce the wages of some
narrow group of workers or change of
organisations in such a way that doesn't
benefit everybody certainly they could
do so to some degree that some people
benefit more than others but overall
wage growth is always going to be a
consequence of that and because wage
growth is going to increase labor demand
the willingness of people to actually
work employment is going to follow the
increases in wages so enabling
technologies thus are of the sort that
will lift all boats they will tend to
benefit workers not come at the expense
of workers that is not so for replacing
technologies because replacing
technologies directly take away tasks
that were produced previously by workers
they create a first order displacement
effect so previously there were several
workers who manned the assembly lines of
the car factories now the machines and
the robots come and those workers lose
their jobs that creates a negative
effect on employment and a negative
effect on wages is it the case that
display replacing technologies always
have a negative effect on employment the
answer is also no because in addition to
the displacement effect they create a
whole host of positive influences and in
particular let's think about this in the
context of the car factories that I have
already used as an example imagine that
General Motors now introduces robots in
order to produce cars on its assembly
lines what does that do well the first
order the first impact of this will be
that General Motors is doing that
because robots are cheaper so if robots
are cheaper than workers then the cost
of producing cars goes down and the
production the cost of cars means that
people will want to consume more cars to
the extent that not everything has been
automated there are you know millions of
non production jobs associated with the
auto industry in the United States as
well as several hundred thousands of
tens of thousands of production work
still around related to auto workers
those lay their demand for labour that
performs these non production and
production tasks in the auto industry is
going to increase because the lower cost
of autos is going to mean people are
going to want to buy
that's one facet of a productivity
effect but there is more the reduction
in the cost of autos means that we're
all richer if we are richer we don't
just want to consume autos we want to
consume all sorts of other things in
particular we would want to have better
health care better entertainment perhaps
better widgets for our home and all of
these increased demands will translate
into employment effects so therefore for
replacing technologies as opposed to the
enabling technologies there is this race
between the displacement effect and the
productivity effect when will the
productivity effect win out when will it
lose out so that the displacement effect
is greater and technologies destroy jobs
and destroy reduce wages the first one
the first element here is that if the
productivity effect is weak then we are
in trouble and this is actually a very
important point if you read the popular
media the picture that's painted and
it's an interesting picture but a
picture is here that's painted is one in
which we have these brilliant
technologies that can perform everything
so much better than humans can do and
that's why we're all going to be thrown
out of work but if those technologies
are really so great they would also
reduce costs a lot so they would
generate a huge productivity effect
actually what we should be scared of are
not those brilliant technologies but the
source or technologies they replace
workers but they don't reduce your cost
all that much if that's the case you
lose the workers the displacement effect
but the productivity effect doesn't kick
in the second element that needs to be
bear borne in mind is whether our
workforce and I'm gonna come back to
this point at the end again whether our
workforce has the skills that are
complementary to machines if we have the
skills complementary to machines then
the increase in the demand for labour
will be stronger but if all that we know
as workers are to perform form the tasks
that computers can perform or robots can
perform but worse then we're really
thrown out of work so therefore the two
elements that we have to warn them bear
in mind in the age of this
replacing technologies is whether we can
combat the displacement effect with
enough productivity improvements so
brilliant technologies were soso
technologies and whether we have the
complementary skills so in this
framework let's now talk a little bit
more about robots and computers so I
think there is no well accepted
definition of what are robots and what
are computers but for this talk I'm
going to use robots as like the
industrial robots that we saw in the car
in the Hindi I plan is they are
automatically controlled with
programmable multi-purpose machines that
autonomously interact with the world the
AI is the word that sometimes used to
refer to the broad cluster of
technologies based on deep learning an
element that Allen already mentioned
that are used for solving and detecting
patterns in in a continuous fashion on
unstructured data and this unstructured
data an algorithmic approach to AI is
actually quite important because there
are some claims in the literature and by
some very very clever people so they are
not to be dismissed but they are based
on the idea that AI is going to be able
to do exactly everything that humans do
and in fact that was the original model
of AI cybernetics and the artificial
intelligence technologies that followed
on it in the 1970s originally thought
that we could program machines to think
exactly like humans that led to a total
failure and probably setback the field
of AI by about 20 years and then the
second wave based on neural networks
algorithmic approaches to unstructured
data deep learning and various other
applications of huge power of today's
computers let take took a different
approach there is no attempt to
replicate the human mind but there is an
attempt to single out tasks and perform
those tasks and generally in the ai ai
domain those are tasks that are just
about information processing now the
importance of that is that
if the world is one in which AI is going
to keep on doing this it's not going to
totally replace humans because it's not
going to replace the human mind so there
is no issue and in fact we're gonna see
that the evidence is not suggesting that
either there is no issue of AI
completely replacing humans but AI is
continuously going to take away from the
tasks that humans were previously
performing and that's going to lead to a
sort of a race between machines and man
which I'm going to talk about now robots
were for a long time
viewed as things that were just gonna be
very very limited in what they could do
because there are a whole host of things
that come naturally to humans that are
very difficult for machines but now this
is for example Baxter it's a robot
that's very good at folding shirts so
that's one of the tasks that people
thought was gonna be very difficult for
robots to perform 10 years ago now it's
fairly routine typical applications of
AI that we have seen already quite
important improvements are things like
financial planning tax preparation but
there are also more creative
applications for instance recent work by
several academics at Cornell and Harvard
shows that if you use AI techniques in
order to perform bail decisions they're
gonna do about 25 percent better than
judges in in keeping the same amount of
people locked up for bail but reducing
the crime rate by 25 percent because
judges are just not processing the
information and are making the wrong
decisions so that's just like if snippet
of the types of things that AI is going
to be able to do so let me now come to
the US data so I already sort of
anticipated some of this by saying there
are really big changes and here are two
of those the dotted line there is the
labor share in employment and the dark
line is the employment rate of prime
aged men so if you go back 35 years you
would see that almost 90 percent 95 so
almost 95 percent of prime aged men
would be working to that today that
number
is just above 80 so the employment rate
of man is declining and that is not
unrelated to the fact that the work that
they are doing is being less and less
compensated and you can see that with
the red dotted line where the share of
labour income in national income stood
around 66 percent about 35 years ago and
now it's just about 56 percent now this
is the aggregate picture but perhaps
more interesting is what's going on to
the level of wages and also to the
distribution of wages so and again the
first way that the economist thought
about this issue was using this sort of
enabling technologies but one strong
implication of the enabling technologies
as I pointed out is that you should not
have these productivity improvements
associated with real wage declines so
here what I'm showing you is the u.s.
wage picture and you are seeing the high
school dropouts the blue workers with
high school degree which are the red
green some college workers with college
degree yellow and those with greater
than college postgraduate degrees the
light blue now look at the beginning of
the picture that's starting in 1963 but
you can go a little bit further back
using other data the pattern is the same
until about 1974 that's the period of
rapid wage growth and wage growth of all
five groups more or less parallel that's
the period of the rising technological
tide lifting all boats so if you were
living through that and some people hear
words you would be in the middle of a
buoyant labor market and a view based on
enabling technologies would just fit
like a glove
but then the picture changes over the
last 35 years we are seeing first slower
wage growth the rate at which these
curves are all increasing even the top
one is slower than what was going on in
the 1960s and early 70s second you are
seeing this fanning out of these
pictures much greater increase in
inequality constant steady increase in
inequality between say workers with
college degree and those without or Dork
workers with postgraduate degrees and
those with
but most importantly for this debate
between enabling and replacing
technologies you also see that the three
bottom groups high school graduates high
school dropouts and those with some
college are experiencing quite
significant real wage declines over this
period something that again the enabling
technologies framework says it shouldn't
happen so this is a telltale sign that's
something that's out of the ordinary
from the sort of the simplest textbook
model that you can imagine in fact even
more troubling perhaps to some people is
that if you look at the yellow line
yellow curve the college graduates are
not doing that well they did not
experience the initial decline in the
wages that high school graduates for
example did but then they had a fairly
anemic growth and the gap between
post-grad rose and the college graduates
is increasing steadily over the last 15
years now these are different education
groups perhaps with a composition of who
is a college graduate and whose equality
who's the high school graduates is
changing so here is the picture when you
just look at the overall wage
distribution so here the green line is
the 90th percentile of the wage
distribution the red line is the median
of the wage and the blue line is the
bottom 10% so you see fairly anemic
growth of wages at the median so US
workers are not scoring wage growth
during this period even though
productivity is growing even though the
US is becoming very rich even though we
are seeing this brilliant mind-boggling
technologies but even more concerning in
some sense - relative to what we are
used to the middle is doing even worse
than the bottom look at the blue curve
from the 1990 onwards it's grows more
than the red curve so the middle is the
one that's most anemic and that is
underscored by this picture also so what
this picture does is that on the
horizontal axis it ranks different
occupations by their skill requirements
or level of wages thus the two actually
turn out to be very similar here I think
is the real level of wages but if you do
it by skill level is the same also and
then on the vertex
Laxus it shows how much employment
changed in the indicated occupation for
the relevant decade in particular the
red curve is for the 1980s the blue
curve is for the 1990s and the red curve
the Greek gray curve is for the mm so
the 1980s is exactly the pattern that
you would expect this is the period in
which the skilled occupations managers
supervisors engineers economists they're
all increase perience seeing not just
wage growth but they're also
experiencing employment growth employers
want to hire more managers they want a
few more production workers which are in
the middle of the occupations they don't
want any of these occupations that are
very very low and in the scale like
protection services like cleaning stuff
and so on and so forth it's the more
skilled occupations for which there is
the demand is increasing but the picture
changes radically in 2000 which is the
blue curve in the blue curve instead of
this increasing pattern which says more
employment growth in the more skilled
occupations you have the u-shape
University in the U shape which says
that you have more employment growth at
the bottom and more employment growth at
the top the middle is where you see
negative employment growth so this is
the period where we are seeing many of
these production jobs the assembly line
work disappearing because some of it
because of globalization but a lot of it
because of technology but to compensate
for that there is much faster growth of
the jobs at the two ends skilled
occupations are still growing but the
bottom is also growing what are less
bottom occupations those are the
cleaning services low low skilled health
care protection other menial tasks part
of this is that people who are losing
their jobs in the middle go and D skill
they take lower skill lower ranked
occupations but the picture becomes even
more striking when you look at the gray
one the 2000s now in the 2000s you have
just grows at the bottom you
have any growth in the high-skill
occupations you don't have any growth in
the middle but just at the bottom so
we're just producing relatively low
skilled jobs the jobs in the lowest pay
lowest skilled occupations so this is an
alarming picture because it says that
from the age where technology was
complementing and creating jobs for
engineers and production workers the
1980s if you go back earlier 70s will be
the same also you are transitioning to a
period in which first the middle then
perhaps later the top is has ceased to
expand and this is not just a u.s.
phenomenon here is data from the OECD so
you can read the names of the different
countries and what this picture does is
that it shows you changes in the
employment of different types of
occupations in particular the green is
the highest-paid occupations the blue is
the lowest paid occupation and the red
is the 1/3 of the middle occupations
from the beginning of the 1990s to the
mid 2000s and what you see is that in
every country that you have here for
which we have data the middle is
shrinking there are less and less jobs
of the production worker and clerical
pipe which were the breadwinners for
many families met for men and women is
this the effect of technology well there
are many things going on as I mentioned
there is globalization
there are institutional changes we have
a total cultural and life changes that
have been engulfing the United States
and other countries throughout this
period so we need to look at more
carefully at what's going on to specific
technologies and here I'm going to just
give you a little bit of a feel for that
by looking at the spread of industrial
robots so what I have done here is I
have taken data on which industries are
adopting robots and then by looking at
the local distribution of employment
determined which sorts of local areas
safe
Flint Michigan vs. Wisconsin or Greater
Boston versus Lowell and Lawrence which
are the areas that are more at greater
risk of robots replacing workers the
darker color means those are the places
that are more exposed to robots and you
see where the exposure to robots is
greatest it's the greatest in the
industrial heartland of the United
States the Rust Belt to some degree
going way all the way down to on the on
the East Coast corridor under under on
the right hand side I have shown the
same US map but now with imports from
China because whenever you talk about
technology one alternative explanation
that people come up with what about
outsourcing what about offshoring what
about textile jobs or other jobs going
to China and being back imported back
into the United States yes indeed that's
a lot of that going on also it's also
interesting that the correlation between
these two things
imports from China and robots is
actually quite weak that correlation if
you don't put anything else the spatial
correlation would be 0.05 very very low
level of correlation and that reflects
the fact that robots and influence plays
things like the auto manufacturers
chemical electronics metal products
whether China imports we're talking of
simple assembly jobs Parral furniture
toys and textile very different
industries and their geographic
distribution is also very different so
then let's look at what's happened
during this period in which robots
penetrated the US economy what's
happened to the employment level of
places that were more exposed to robots
again in a world of enabling
technologies we should see these places
thrive both productivity wise but also
in terms of employment and wages and
this picture here shows that the effect
is actually not very positive at all
places that have been more exposed to
robots have had significant shrinkage in
their employment so the extreme point
there is Flint Michigan that's the one
that's most exposed for example but
you'll see that many other places are
very exposed also and have experienced
rather rough
it roll out of industrial robots and
their employment hasn't done very well
same thing when you look at wages wage
levels have been not just stagnant but
actually declining in the areas that are
most on the firing line of robots so
therefore I take this evidence as
suggestive that just as in the
discussion that I provided at the
beginning of replacing technologies we
are in the midst of a process where we
have an array of different replacing
technologies industrial robots is just
one example but the oncoming AI
revolution is an even bigger and bigger
one and if indeed as appears to have
been the case if these technologies are
not creating a productivity revolution
and I'll talk a little bit about that in
a second and we don't really have the
complimentary skills the displacement
effect is gonna win out and we should
experience lower wages and lower
employment and that's what we are seeing
but it also should be added immediately
that the numbers here are not
apocalyptic we're not talking of
millions of people losing jobs so if you
take the numbers that I'm showing you
here it would imply that robots reduced
US employment by one third of a
percentage point so not trivial but
nothing relative to the huge decline in
employment in manufacturing for example
which is more than three percentage
points so during the same period so
we're not talking about the endo job but
we are talking powerful technologies
that may be pushing us in the direction
that we have to deal with these now if
this is the case where will jobs come
from well there are two scenarios there
are two views and I want to talk about
both of these views and these views
relate to what I just talked about the
complementarity issue one view is the
optimistic scenario which starts by
noting that automation is not a new
phenomenon we've been automating we've
been experiencing new technologies
throughout the ages but whereas
automation goes on we create complement
three tasks we find new ways in which
humans are useful we create new things
when the railroads come and replace the
horse-drawn carriages we create a whole
host of new occupations associated with
the railroad engineers conductors
maintenance workers finance tiers and
managers in the same way that when
computers come came we created a whole
host of computerized radiology computer
engineers software developers and and
very different versions of many of the
tasks that were manual in advance so if
in this figure what you see is that if
you look at the past the last the the
three decades up to 2007 in the United
States a lot of the work about half of
the employment growth in the u.s. comes
from the creation of new tasks on the
horizontal axis you have how much of new
tasks there are embedded in a new
occupations and you see that occupations
that have more new tasks are growing
more rapidly so this is where the lever
that I talked about which is creating
complementary skills for technologies is
important because one way in which we
can do that is by creating new tasks
that are going to generate high wage
employment opportunities but there is
the pessimistic view which is not crazy
either because that's very much informed
from the 2000s as you saw in the 2000s
we did not create was the industrial
robots were coming on and automation was
progressing very rapidly we did not
create many new tasks that were
high-paying
instead we created a lot more of these
workers who are in food preparation
cleaning protection services and low
skill health healthcare perhaps the
future is going to be one in which
robots and a I are gonna take all of the
high-skilled jobs and and then we're
gonna be left with with these jobs for a
very large fraction of the US population
that's a question about predicting the
future but it's also a question about
policy because I think the line that
demurred demarcates these two scenarios
is not a given one is one that depends
on what sorts of skills our workforce
has if our workforce has no skills that
can be in great demand in
wage jobs of course they will have to go
and work in protection services on food
preparation but with a differently
skilled workforce the scenario could be
very different but a lot of this then
comes down to how much productivity we
are generating from these new
technologies as I've already noted
several times if you are in the world of
disability replacing technologies you
need to fight the displacement effect to
some degree with the complementary
skills but to a great degree with these
productivity effects do we have those
productivity effects and here the
picture in the popular press and the
discussions that you may have followed
on the web is even more convenient
confusing because on the one hand there
are economists and engineers and a AI
scientists who are predicting the
arrival of infinite wealth because our
machines are becoming so and so are
becoming so productive and for example
Kurzweil singularity thesis and many
other computer scientists and AI
specialists are predicting machines that
can produce machines and can do
everything so efficiently that we can
have the age of plenty on the other hand
we have people such as Robert Gordon who
created an unlikely bestseller last year
with a book that heralded the arrival of
low productivity growth in the next
several decades so which one is the case
well let's first of all look at the data
the data actually is more firmly on
Robert Gordon's side at least at first
sight here is the productivity growth
multi-factor productivity growth how
much we are increasing our ability to
produce things for when you control for
labor and capital and that productivity
growth was indeed very rapid in the 30s
40s up all the way up to the 70s and
then look at what's going on in the age
of the AI computers and robotics it's
been much slower now people will say
well we're not measuring productivity
and so on and so forth and correctly and
there is some truth to that but a lot of
the problems with measurement apply to
the 50s and the 60s and the 70s also so
that's not a complete explanation
so I think what's going on is that we
are reliving what Bob Solow my colleague
at MIT and who one of the founders of
growth economics anticipated in 1987 in
a New York Review of Books he said we
can see the computer age everywhere but
in the productivity statistics and at
the time everybody said this is a
temporary phenomenon it's gonna be
another 10 years and now it's been 35
it's been 30 years since Bob Solow wrote
that and we still don't see it as the
previous picture shows so what is going
on the optimistic view is that still
this is temporary and we are making it
much much worse because we are not
counting Wikipedia we're not counting
all the services that Google provides
and once you count them productivity is
not so bad and it's going to improve but
I think a much more relevant perspective
or at least the one that I would
subscribe is related to the issue of the
complementary skills that I have already
highlighted which is that we are facing
many bottlenecks new technologies
robotics AI require complementary skills
require other technological improvements
so that they can work very well they can
require organizational changes so
imagine your car for example in so many
ways its superior to the cars that you
were driving 30 years ago but at the end
of the day you can drive it no faster
and it cannot get you from A to B any
faster in fact it will get you from A to
B much slower than you did 30 years ago
because traffic regulations haven't
changed roads are very congested and
there are actually parts of the car that
have not kept up with those improvements
such as tires or other safety safety
technologies that wouldn't really stand
you driving at hundred and 20 miles an
hour
so all of those widgets that have
improved the internal combustion engine
and added to the car they're not useful
because there are other bottlenecks and
if you look at history history really
emphasizes the importance of such
bottlenecks and I will just conclude
with this brief discussion of what the
economic historian Bob Allen has called
angles pose
if you want to compare our age a
wonderful brilliant mind-boggling
technologies that are coming from every
corner to another one I think there is
no better candidate than the age of the
Industrial Revolution starting from 1760
in Britain and then later in other parts
of Western Europe you've had these waves
of technologies that people could not
even imagine and started a process of
changing automating improving production
processes all around in the economy and
changing people's lives but what
happened
well productivity growth was actually
pretty slow and for 90 years
there was no wage growth and Bob Allen
calls this angles post this is what
Frederick Engel was motivated by saying
there's not gonna be any wage growth it
lasted for 90 years how come these
wonderful technologies were changing
things so radically and we're not seeing
any wage growth well we can look at one
specific technology and one specific
occupation Weavers well what happened
with Weaver's well one thing what
happened is that when the first power
looms were introduced they did increase
productivity by several fold but at the
same time they also displaced Weaver's
from certain tasks and they were not
adopted in a way that was brought within
the whole economy so some companies made
the switch to the power loom some others
didn't and the demand for Weaver's did
not really increase it took another 50
years for the power loom to spread and
go through several more iterations so
that productivity now increased by 24
and it is only at that point that the
demand for textile workers increased
quite strongly and you start seeing some
wage growth so it really was the
culmination of the technological changes
that led to the whole industry changing
and many complementary technologies and
organizational improvements being made
at the same time but I think even this
understates the complexity of the task
of dealing with the arrival of new
technologies because while this was
happening the power loom was spreading
and was becoming more productive in the
weaving industry
there were many many more more
consequential changes taking place in
the British society for example starting
in 1818 32 Britain became a democracy or
started first steps towards democracy
and ultimately extending the suffrage
more and more to universal suffrage both
the men and women in the course of about
80 years in the in the the two decades
following 1832 universal education
started being introduced you labor
unions started negotiating wages in a
way that started protecting workers so
therefore there was a whole slew of
institutional changes that were adopted
and started being adapted to the
technological revolutions that the
British society was experiencing at the
end of the 18th and the beginning of the
19th century
so if looked at it that way we are very
much at the beginning of it and we are
at the very much at the beginning of it
without really having a map about how
the future should look like and I think
that's the most important lesson that I
want to underscore in closing these
remarks I think we are really very much
in the middle of some very
transformative changes and the way to
deal with these changes is to understand
them better to make knowledge based
quantitatively sound assessments about
what they are doing and what they are
likely to do and change our own
investments our own policy positions and
our own institutions in a way that's
coherent with this picture thank you
very much
[Applause]